Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Fantastic Four Doctor Doom video apparently
Marvel was ready to cast Robert Downey Jr as
a version of Doctor Doom so we'll break it all
down because it's a really cool reveal from Kevin
feige and John Favreau if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
because there are a lot of deleted scenes and
Easter eggs featuring The Doctor Doom character
in the newer Marvel movies that I'll point out
too should we talk about that because I think
that's probably one of the greatest decisions
in the history of of Hollywood Robert had come in
for a general on it and I remember you had all met
with him already for like Dr Doom or something on
another project I think on on on I think he had
come through on a pre like maybe Fantastic Four
right everybody has good days and bad days and I
remember on later movies we'll talk about a 15th
anniversary of those there were dark days and I
would say Robert we wouldn't be in this mess it
wasn't for you meaning we wouldn't have a studio
if it wasn't for it's true or you tell me your
memories of of where that idea came from because
there was some other people so everybody sort of
knew who he was and I I remember sitting down with
the guy and I was like geez he just got it and
he's got that spark in him and his eye and he's
ready and that's when we were in your office and
and we were pointing to his headshot and saying we
got to try to figure this out the way they talk
about it he was going up for Doctor Doom during
the original Fantastic Four movie and that would
have been around 2003 2004 when they were casting
that role when he was in the middle of making Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang with Shane black who they would
later hire to direct Iron Man 3. and originally
there was an earlier version of that first Iron
Man movie that they tried to make with Tom Cruise
is Iron Man Tony Stark which is why they were all
those Doctor Strange two Iron Man Tom Cruise
rumors like oh he's coming back around like
they were paying off this Easter egg that didn't
wind up working out when they originally thought
to make him a version of Iron Man in the MCU the
other funny thing about that original Fantastic
Four movie is that mass Mickelson auditioned for
Reed Richards but lost out to Joan gruffit think
about all the really dark characters that he's
played since then like he'd be perfect Doctor
Doom let me know what you think about the idea
of Robert Danny Jr playing a version of Doctor
Doom I feel like he could pull it off just because
he's a fantastic actor but his version of Doctor
Doom would probably be a little more unhinged like
he's got that crazy energy about him that's in the
Tony Stark character especially early on before
he matures a little bit over the course of the
infinity Saga right now we have spider-verse
coming out it's a big Multiverse movie we
have a Multiverse Saga happening right now maybe
someday we'll see Multiverse versions of Doctor
Doom played by mass Mickelson and Robert Downey
Jr speaking of which I'm giving away spider-verse
tickets to just random people in the comments
of this video and thank you to private internet
access VPN for sponsoring this week's giveaway
a VPN is a tool that hides your IP address and
safeguards your internet connection through an
encrypted tunnel it also allows you to change your
online geo location normally on my Marvel or DC
videos I do giveaways for Disney Plus or HBO Max
subscriptions or Netflix subscriptions but some
of you probably live in countries that don't have
access to those streaming services or episodes
get locked in something we like to call Netflix
Alex jail were the only available in certain
countries but with private internet access VPN
you can actually change the location you
access content online from so even if you
live outside the United States or North America
just download private internet access connect to
a us or UK server and you'll get anything that
they're blocking in your country they even give
it a huge shout out during Spider-Man far from
home by the way travel tip you should probably
download a VPN on your phone just so that the
government can track you while we're abroad smart
she's not wrong you can also use the VPN to stop
anyone from snooping on your browsing history that
was even a major plot point during the Hawkeye
series and right now they're giving away the
service at an 83 percent discount all you have to
do is use my link in the description I'll put it
on screen here too and you get an extra four
months for free they do have a 30-day refund
policy too if you decide it's not for you that
works out to about two dollars and three cents
a month to protect an unlimited amount of devices
that you own and there's no limit on the number of
people who can get the deal so everyone watching
the video can claim it so be sure to check it out
they're in the middle of casting the new versions
of the Fantastic Four MCU actors right now we just
saw John Krasinski and Doctor Strange 2 as the
838 Universe version of the character so we've
already started to see Fantastic Four stuff
in the background of the MCU reportedly we're
not supposed to see the MCU version of Dr Doom
though for a couple more years at least like there
might be some references to him during this new
Fantastic Four movie but he's not supposed to be a
big character during that reportedly they're going
to use Galactus as a big one the scale is again in
that all is as it was perfectly balanced this
whole thing should be it is known by many names
why people called it Galactus the Devourer of
Worlds and it'll actually be terrax that will be
his Herald not Silver Surfer so also be a little
bit longer before we actually see Silver Surfer
in the MCU there have been a couple deleted scenes
in Easter eggs for Doctor Doom in the newer Marvel
movies though probably the biggest one was during
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness because the
director Sam Raimi the writer specifically
talked about the Doctor Doom character when
they were writing parts of the movie the detail
of the teleportation device he uses to get into
the scene is something we took from the comics
that's Dr Tunes Dr Doom's uh time door what
they're talking about is actually right out of the
comics the whole idea is that Kang basically finds
Dr Doom's Museum in an old doombot and takes
his technology to create his first time travel
device taking it back in time to ancient Egypt to
become the Rama Tut version of Kang which we saw
recently during Ant-Man the WASP Quantum Mania
that's meant to be him at the beginning of his
timeline eventually the Fantastic Four found out
what he was doing because it was happening in a
Fantastic Four comic book one of the earliest
ones they go back stop him and he escapes to
the Future to become king the Conqueror like he
changes his name to Kang then keeps coming back
to fight The Avengers through different parts of
the timeline you're an Avenger have I killed you
before they all blow together after a while you're
not the one with the hammer it's Thor so in the
838 Universe there is a version of Doctor Doom
that's active in this universe they just didn't
cast an actor to play him in the movie one of the
kings in the background here during Ant-Man the
wasp's quantumania post credit scene is also the
Doctor Doom version of Kang so they're actually
two different versions of Dr Doom Kang one is
Doctor Doom becoming a version of Kang and the
other is Kang pretending to be Doctor Doom this is
just meant to be a version of Kang in an alternate
universe that's pretending to be doctored him
which is why his armor looks like doctor Doom's
armor the version of Doctor Doom that becomes a
version of Kang is called Doom the annihilating
Conqueror that's more like Dune taking the
powers of Kang during black panther wakanda
forever which takes place in the MCU a big plot
point is the other nations of the world searching
for vibranium at the beginning of the movie
originally Lake Bell's character was supposed
to be a version of Lucia Von Barta who's one of Dr
Doom's underlings from lot varia and she was going
to secretly be working for for him to find that
underwater vibranium so Dr Doom is looking for
vibranium in the MCU also during the Moon Knight
series when he winds up in that foreign country
in the background there is a castle that looks
just like the castles of lot varia and the writers
also specifically said that was meant to be an
Easter egg like yeah he's probably in a version of
lot very when he's waking up here you can let me
know who you want to play that new MCU version of
Doctor Doom but there are also lots of Easter eggs
for Robert Downey Jr showing up in future Marvel
movies as other characters or other versions of
characters too deleted scenes from previous movies
and Easter eggs there was a deleted scene from
Avengers Infinity War where he briefly becomes
sorcerer Supreme rescuing Dr Strange and Doctor
Strange also becomes the iron Mage wearing his
Iron Man armor there are also newer rumors about
Robert Downey Jr now coming back as a version of
that Superior Iron Man of the 838 universe that
they didn't wind up casting an actor for in Doctor
Strange 2 trying to get revenge for Scarlet Witch
killing the Illuminati maybe we'll see a version
of that during a Avengers 5 King Dynasty or like
some small Easter egg because there are rumors
that part of Avengers 5 and Avengers 6 will borrow
from the plot of Avengers forever which involves
a version of Kang using an evil Avengers team
from Another Universe to fight the good Avengers
so during King Dynasty we could see some of these
actors come back as The Avengers but as alternate
universe versions that are evil fighting the new
Avengers then a lot of other cool details that
Kevin feige and John Favreau talk about with
Robert Downey Jr just the history of the MCU
a big part of his process when they were making
the first Iron Man movie Robert Downey Jr's was
rewriting the script every day with the director
of the other creatives just to make whatever they
were shooting the next day even better and one
of the big tipping points that they credit is
the original Comic-Con event in 2007 where
they showed off the first trailer but also
before that Kevin feige actually did a Comic-Con
panel where he specifically called out that they
were making the Avengers like oh we're making a
Captain America movie we're doing a Thor movie
we're doing an Incredible Hulk movie and they're
all gonna meet up and cross over in The Avengers
so even before the first Iron Man movie was
released the MCU had already started to take
shape and the whole MCU of it all was one of the
reasons why fans were even more hyped especially
long-term comic book fans like oh they're all
connected all these things are going to cross
over and we're going to build up to something
even bigger the whole Grand Design of it which was
Thanos The Infinity Gauntlet Avengers Infinity war
and Avengers end game and now I'm actually kind of
glad that Robert Downey Jr wasn't that original
Dr Doom in the original Fantastic Four movies
because even though they have their moments like
they're a couple good moments in there generally
those original Fantastic Four movies aren't that
great and even Kevin feige and John Favreau now
talk about Robert Downey Jr being cast as Iron
Man being one of the greatest things to ever
happen in the history of Hollywood like one of
the most fantastic pairings of an actor and a
character you almost can't imagine him playing any
other characters the other funny thing too is when
they start talking about Samuel L Jackson as Nick
Fury they said that behind the scenes they think
of him as Gandalf or at the time they thought of
him as Gandalf a character that just shows up out
of nowhere when you need him and helps you and
then disappears he then described him as we were
going forward as Gandalf that he would appear when
needed with answers and I always thought that was
very smart idea for for Fury suggested the all the
way at the end of the credit area remember when we
showed it to him at Scott Walker it was it was
just after the first few credits he's like he's
like the whole end yeah Ferris Bueller style yes
there's also a funny connection to the Deadpool
movies too like we're making Deadpool 3 right now
they literally just started filming it Kevin feige
refers to that original Iron Man post-credits
scene as pulling a Ferris Bueller putting it
at the very end of the credits and during the
first Deadpool movie they specifically parodied
that Ferris Bueller post credit scene but in
a much more literal way in related Fantastic
Four news we will hear confirmations about who
some of the major characters are really soon we
probably won't find out who's gonna play that
new Doctor Doom for a couple more years though
speaking of Nick Fury click here for my brand
new secret Invasion trailer video in Easter
eggs and click here for my brand new Captain
America 4 First Look breakdown in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!